un bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le
journal de tv 78 l'info locale en 26
minutes ça nous sommes le jeudi 12
septembre voici les titres de
l'actualité
trois mois que les pompiers des yvelines
sont en grève ils ont répondu fin juin à
l'appel national de plusieurs
organisations syndicales un mouvement
pour dénoncer au départ un manque
d'effectifs mais aussi pour demander une
remise à plat du régime des retraites
c'est le premier transport du genre à
circuler quotidiennement en france un
bus à hydrogène et testé en ce moment
entre versailles et jouy en josas otomen
autonomie de 300 km pour ce véhicule qui
a été inauguré officiellement ce matin
et du golfe jouer avec les pieds c'est
le principe du fou de golf la discipline
se développe avec 5000 licenciés
français aujourd'hui une compétition
s'est déroulée il ya quelques jours à la
q les yvelines on parlera aussi à tout à
l'heure du mouvement de grève qui se
profilait lundi chez les avocats et
aussi de la plaine de versailles qui
entre en fait à quelques jours de
l'automne
[Musique]
depuis la fin juin les pompiers
yvelinois ont répondu à l'appel national
lancé par une intersyndicale cela elle
ne s'était pas produit en 20 ans 85% à
des sapeurs pompiers sont en grève
remise à plat du système des retraites
revalorisation de la prime de feu mais
aussi plus d'effectifs le point sur la
mobilisation avec mathilde domini les
revendications sont multiples et le
mouvement de la greffe s'attaque à
chaque département pour les pompiers des
yvelines la principale requête concerne
le manque d'effectif 140 postes sont
demandés pour remplir les camions lors
des interventions
les délais d'intervention augmenté dans
tout le département dont cadets en a
pour qui ça n'a pas bougé et d'autres
qui ont pris 10 15 20 minutes
supplémentaires à des interventions du
fait de la disponibilité des pompiers à
cet instant dans le centre concerné
c'est de remettre en effectif suffisant
dans les engins comme c'est prévu ou un
fourgon incendie on doit de 6,2 dans
cinq quatre trois ça marche pas
forcément derrière le service n'est plus
du tout le même intervenir dans de
bonnes conditions c'est la volonté de
ces sapeurs la profession des pompiers
n'est pas encore reconnue comme
dangereuse et insalubres ce qui ne leur
permet pas de prendre leur retraite
avant 62 voire 64 ans on sait que
l'espérance de vie d'un pompier est de
65 ans on a un métier qui est dangereux
pénible on intervient sur tout partout
pour tous même pour des missions qui ne
sont pas les nôtres on est exposé en
première ligne tout le temps ces
pompiers qui subissent des charges de
travail importantes mais aussi des
agressions lors des interventions ne
supportent plus leur rythme de travail
contacté par la rédaction la direction
du sdi 78 n'a pour l'instant pas
souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet la
grève des pompiers risque de
s'intensifier dans les jours à venir
c'est une actualité qui causent la
grogne parmi plusieurs professions le
gouvernement planche actuellement sur
une réforme des retraites objectifs
notamment fondre les quarante deux
régimes spéciaux en un seul régime
universel le premier ministre edouard
philippe à préciser aujourd'hui devant
le conseil économique et environnemental
le calendrier et la méthode est la
réforme sera mise en place
progressivement pour les personnes
après 1963 application définitive prévue
en 2040
et non content de ce qu'il se prépare
plusieurs professions entame un bras de
fer des mobilisations massives 1 dont
une prévue demain à la ratp on vous en
parle dans un instant elle les avocats
se feront front commun lundi avec
plusieurs professions libérales pour une
manifestation à paris on en parle avec
vous m nicolas good ce bon soir tombant
soir vous êtes avocat au barreau de
versailles membre du conseil de l'ordre
les avocats qui font partie bien sûr de
ses 42 régime spécifique que le
gouvernement prévoit est de fusionner en
un seul en étant déjà le plus
pédagogique possible est ce que vous
pouvez expliquer comment fonctionne
votre système actuel de retraites alors
vous l'avez déjà rappelé à régime
spécifique il est même autonome en fait
un régime autonome c'est-à-dire que il
est géré par une caisse nationale des
barreaux de france qui est totalement
indépendante
une gestion généreuse et une gestion
solidaire autonome c'est à dire que ce
sont les avocats qui cotisent pour leur
retraite
et ça ne coûte absolument rien à l'état
ni ni à quiconque et une gestion
solidaire parce qu'à une seule est
d'arrêter à la fois interne c'est à dire
que le système est si vertueux que nous
cotisons pour partie forfaitairement de
façon tout à fait raisonnable ce qui
permet d'assurer une retraite minimale
tout à fait satisfaisante pour nos
confrères annuités égal et une
solidarité externe car
nous cotisons également auteur d'à peu
près mille trois cents euros par avocat
par an pour la collectivité nationale et
notamment pour apporter une aide aux
collectivités aux régimes qui serait
déficitaire rien d'après vous vos propos
c'est un système aujourd'hui qui
fonctionne très bien il n'a pas besoin
de modification a priori non vertueux
qui répond aux objectifs de solidarité
qui sont qui sont avancés tout à fait
vertueux qui est bénéficiaire nous avons
deux milliards de réserve parce que pour
être totalement objectif
on a une période démocratique qui est
démographique est extrêmement favorable
puisque quatre avocats actifs pour un
retraité actuellement voilà mais c'est
un système une autogestion qui est qu'à
6 mai parfaite idéal qui pourrait être
remis en cause en tout cas on le verra
dans les prochains arbitrages du
gouvernement avec cette réforme des
retraites vous serez dans la rue lundi
avec d'autres professions vous estimez
du coup que ce projet de réforme
pourrait mettre en péril votre
profession si oui pourquoi
oui alors c'est effectivement une
question qui est majeure d'abord je
voudrais si vous le permettez rappeler
très rapidement un chiffre actuellement
parce que on a toujours une image de
profession de dentiste qui est
extrêmement compliqué à gérer
aujourd'hui le revenu médian des avocats
annuel c'est 43000 euros
quelqu'un qui va déclarer 24000 euros
par an aujourd'hui avec notre système
qui cotisaient 3700 euros par an et il
avait une retraite de 20 mille 600 euros
par an soit à peu près 1000 724 euros
par mois avec la réforme
demain ces cotisations elles sont de
6700 euros par an pour une retraite de
4000 euros par an autrement dit par
train d'y perdre à 600 euros de retraite
alors qu'ils cotisent ras al amoud deux
fois plus de 14%
d'ailleurs des 1,28 pour des effets même
sur le court terme peut être moins de
pouvoir d'achat pour les hommes -
pouvoir échanger c'est surtout la mort
des structures des petites structures en
fait d'exercice et vous savez ce qui est
extrêmement version de vicieux et vous
allez voir si absolument pas égocentré
comme comme discours en sais que vous
allez toucher en fait aux structures les
plus modestes et les structures les plus
modestes c'est celle qui assure le plus
les missions de service public et
notamment via l'aide juridictionnelle le
secteur assisté et donc si vous voulez
privé si vous augmentez
asik mans et de façon significative
leurs cotisations retraite ils ne
pourront plus accepté d'intervenir comme
ils le font pour l'aide juridictionnelle
et donc qui va en payer le prix
vous pourriez aussi avoir un risque pour
un risque pardon pour le justiciable
c'est ça qu'ils soient qui est qu'il est
moins d'accès au droit finalement ya un
excellent elle exactement ça signifie
que les plus démunis vont voir un accès
au droit extrêmement restreint et ce qui
est aussi la deuxième ça c'est le pour
moi l'élément qui est fondamental il ya
une autre difficulté et ça c'est une
rupture d'égalité une injustice
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes salarié que
vous cotisez sur ces 28 % vous en
assumer 40% et les charges patronales
ses 60% ses lentilles les 40 60
l'avocat lui lui il en assurer 100%
c'est une chose et pourtant nous ne
bénéficions pas des mêmes un régime de
protection sociale par exemple nous
n'avons pas d'assurance chômage
donc on nous augmente on a un point ça
c'est pas entrer trop dans la technicité
mais on a un point une valeur du point
qui va de toute façon être restreinte et
dont on ignore exactement le et qu'elle
sera à quel sera le montant et en plus
les réformes qu'on nous a annoncé sur la
protection sociale notamment l'assurance
chômage ne voit pas le jour sur la
mobilisation pour le barreau des deux
sèvres les avocats ont prévu une
mobilisation massive report de la
totalité des audiences lundi compris le
pénal d'urgence est ce que ce sera le
cas à versailles est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à une mobilisation massive
des avocats du barreau de versailles
oui parfaitement ça a été appelée
conformément au cnv keynote organisme
conseil national des barreaux qui est
notre organisme de représentation qui
est qui nous a appelés à café un appel à
la grève pour le 7 septembre la petite
spécificité c'est pour le pénal devant
syrte lors des renvois mais pour le
contentieux la liberté la détention on
n'a pas envie non plus de sacrifier tout
ce qui est ce site dangereux la liberté
qu'est comme fondamental il sera assurée
notamment par le futur bâtonnier du
barreau de versailles mort à pied pour
terminer lundi dans le cortège vous
ferez front commun avec d'autres
professions libérales qui sont réunis
dans un collectif sos retraite ça c'est
primordial d'unir les voiles et les
différentes discorde en une seule voie
pour pas que cette mobilisation de
s'éparpiller
finalement oui c'est très juste en fait
ce à l'initiative du conseil de sun des
barreaux toujours il ya eu un appel à la
mobilisation
en fait on va faire front même si encore
une fois on a un régime autonome on est
pas on n'est pas les seuls dans la rue
autonome en 2k qui fonctionne
extrêmement bien spécifiques une
mobilisation plus forte c'est toujours
c'est toujours important et on est tous
impactés une mobilisation qui est prévue
ce lundi à paris merci nicolas good
d'être venu en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat au barreau de
versailles est également membre du
conseil de l'ordre merci d'avoir
accueilli
il n'y a pas que les avocats qui se
mobilisent pour le maintien de leur
régime spécifique une grève massive est
annoncée également du côté de la ratp ce
vendredi conséquence une journée est
très compliqué dans les transports pour
les yvelinois qui travaille à paris
attention dix lignes de métro seront
totalement fermées demain vous les voyez
s'afficher pour les métros 4 et 7
un train sur trois sera en circulation
aucune rame entre franklin roosevelt et
nation sur la ligne 9 1 train sur 4 pour
le reste du tracé
quant à la ligne 8 prévoir 1 train sur 3
seulement entre créteil et rully est
diderot du côté du réseau des rer
beaucoup de perturbations également pour
le rer a qui s'arrête dans de nombreuses
villes des yvelines pas de trafic aux
heures creuses et seulement une rame sur
trois en heures de pointe c'est à dire
de 6h30 à 9h30 le matin et de 17 heures
à 20 heures le soir à la ligne b dont le
terminus est à saint rémy les chevreuse
sera également interrompu aux heures
creuses
un train sur cinq en prévision pour les
heures de pointe à noter que les autres
rer et transilien pour c'est pour ces
raisons a le trafic est annoncé normal
car gérée par la sncf
enfin pour les tramways pas de
circulation en heures creuses sur le t6
qui passe à vélizy et viroflay tout
comme sur cinq autres lignes
franciliennes que vous voyez à l'écran
un tram sur trois en heures de pointe un
train sur deux sur le t3 bis et le t5
enfin en moyenne un bus sur trois des
lignes ratp roulera sur l'ensemble du
réseau
et justement puisqu'on parlait de bus
est une première nationale des bus à
hydrogène circule dans les yvelines plus
écologiques ces moyens de transport
elles sont en place sur la ligne 264
entre versailles et jouy en josas
inauguration officielle ce matin en gare
de versailles chantiers maxime a bola
silencieux non polluantes
ces bus à hydrogène incarne l'avenir des
transports en commun en expérimentation
dans le département ils ont été conçus
par air liquide
mais ces projets n'en fait est un bus
électrique avec une batterie qui est
plus faible sur les bus électriques
normaux donc 24 kilowatts une batterie
qui est plus petit en kilowatts king
jouet par exemple et qu'il bénéficie
d'une pile à combustible qui charge
cette batterie dès que celle ci descend
en dessous de 50% de charge grâce à cinq
bouteilles d'hydrogène situées sur le
toit le bus garé d'une autonomie de 300
km la recharge s'effectue en 20 minutes
dans une borne située aux loges en josas
un moyen de transport plus écologique
donc mais aussi plus agréable à conduire
ça se conduit pareil c'est ce qu'on est
pareil sauf que l'essai silencieux et
non polluant et ça c'est assez
appréciable et puis je pense que à long
terme en fin de service je pense que je
serai beaucoup moins fatigués par
rapport aux bruits parasites pour aia
qui pouvait y avoir d'un côté tu es en
cas de réussite de ce test l'objectif
sera de déployer ses moyens de transport
sur tout le territoire francilien
mon objectif à court terme et ce sera
l'objet d'une délibération convoitera en
novembre au conseil régional c'est de
déployer des territoires à hydrogène des
territoires à hydrogène en ile de france
qui sont des territoires test je pense
que naturellement autour d'orly il ya
quelque chose à faire naturellement ici
autour de du centre de recherche de
l'air liquide et quelque chose à faire
mais on peut identifier
en ile-de-france un certain nombre de
territoires dans lequel on va déployer
les réseaux de bus et de gênes déployés
aussi des flottes de véhicules à
hydrogène avec les entreprises autour de
stations à hydrogène c'est ça notre
priorité
seul hic de ces nouveaux bus leurs prix
alors qu'un véhicule diesel coûte
environ 250000 euros
le bus à hydrogène est estimé à 850
mille euros
et d'ile-de-france qui se fixent cet
objectif 100 % de bus propres en 2029
autres moyens de transport et qui se
veut plus respectueux de l'environnement
c'est le vélo électrique la région veut
le faire découvrir aux franciliens au
moyen du vélib ou un service de location
longue durée est mise en place par
ile-de-france mobilité il a été lancé
officiellement ce mercredi est le
reportage de marie lehn iapichino et de
rodolphe blondel la très grande majorité
des trajets en voiture aujourd'hui en
ile de france font moins de 7 kilomètres
mois de 7 km c'est à dire 20 minutes un
quart d'heure vingt minutes de vélo ou
de lelo électrique c'est en partant de
ce constat que la région ile de france
avec l'aide d'ile-de-france mobilité a
décidé de lancer son service de location
de vélos électriques longue durée veliko
vingt mille vélos en location longue
durée pour 20 euros par mois avec le
remboursement employeur eh bien on peut
découvrir le vélo électrique pendant six
mois
est ce que je viens d'annoncer c'est que
après ces six mois à partir de février
2020 la région qui veut être un puissant
réducteur d'inégalités sur tout son
territoire proposera pour chaque
francilien quelle que soit la ville où
il habite une aide de 500 euros à
l'achat une aide individuelle de 500
euros à l'achat de vélos électriques de
150 points de location sont mis en place
dans toute la région dont sept à saint
quentin en yvelines
la région souhaite donner l'accès à ce
mode de déplacement souple oh non
parisiens dont le territoire est plus
vallonné vous avez évidemment le moteur
la batterie qui est sûr le cadre qui est
unique et
qui est pour ce vélo qui permet d'être
branché directement si vous habitez en
rez de chaussée sur ce côté latéral ou
de la déloger et de la prendre avec vous
dans votre bureau ou à votre domicile
une batterie d'une autonomie de 75 km
mais également un poste de pilotage où
loger son smartphone avec une prise usb
pour récupérer de l'autonomie 1500
utilisateurs se sont déjà inscrits
durant l'été et parmi eux quatre
chanceux on peut récupérer leur v-league
au mercredi 11 septembre journée
officielle du lancement du service
l'automne vu par certains comme une
période morose après la douceur de l'été
détrompez-vous l'association de la
plaine de versailles lance à la proche
de cette saison sont un automne de la
plaine de versailles ça débute demain
balade conférence est fait
au programme jusqu'au 15 décembre on en
parle en plateau avec vous marie
martinez bonsoir vous êtes chef de
projet à l'association patrimoniale de
la plaine de versailles également louis
bataille en plateau bon soir vous êtes
le cofondateur un des co fondateurs des
deux gourmands des producteurs de
biscuits à crêpière et vous
organisez-vous à samedi et dimanche une
fête de la pleine dans votre
exploitation à crespian on va en parler
dans un instant déjà sur l'automne de la
plaine marie martinez présentez-nous cet
événement quels sont les objectifs de
cet automne les adjectifs donc de
l'automne de la plaine c'est de
rassembler toutes les initiatives qui se
passe sur le territoire de la plaine de
versailles qui rassemble vraiment toutes
les partenaires et acteurs du territoire
pour montrer le dynamisme toutes les
initiatives qui peuvent être prises que
ce soit artistique culturel patrimonial
par exemple avec les journées du
patrimoine lors de l'automne ou d'autres
animations fait par les agriculteurs ou
des producteurs ou comme donc louis des
deux gourmands
ce week-end est juste sur cette
association justement de la plaine de
versailles
quelles sont ses missions qui la
composent et sur quel territoire s'étend
cette association la plaine de
versailles ces 27 communes donc qui
s'étendent après le parc du château de
versailles jusqu'à la vallée de la
mauldre est l'objectif de l'association
c'est de d'être un lieu de rassemblement
d'échangé de partage au niveau de
différents acteurs et utilisateurs du
territoire dans cette idée de bien vivre
ensemble en est constitué de trois
collèges dont pour représenter vraiment
toute cette catégorie de population dont
il ya les élus les différents maires
il ya les agriculteurs et ya ce qu'on
appelle la société civile qui ressemble
les habitants les entreprises et les
associations du territoire et l'objectif
c'est d'être force de proposition et de
faire du développement durable sur la
plaine d'une façon participative est
positive en étant pour un développement
durable et pour un développement
vertueux et pas contre ceci ou cela qui
pourrait être plus réducteur ou opposé
agriculteur habitant fin voilà on est
vraiment dans cette notion d'être dans
la cohabitation le bien vivre ensemble
et du coup loto de la plaine de
versailles commence demain avec un
événement à bailly se faire tout à fait
demain c'est de la commune de ben ali
avec qui encore organise l'événement qui
ouvre le bal de l'automne de la plaine
c'est un événement ouvert à tous les
habitants pour un petit peu échangé sur
le la cohabitation va dire entre
agriculteurs et habitants pour parler
alimentation agriculture biodiversité
est un petit peu ce qui se passe sur la
plaine et de façon ludique avec une
troupe d'impro qui reprendra un peu de
façon humoristique les points forts des
échanges et on retrouve toutes les
informations sur le site de la plaine de
versailles et leurs parmi les adhérents
il ya les deux gourmands qui fabrique
des biscuits salés et sucrés aussi à
crêpière vous organisez je le disais
tout à l'heure ce samedi et dimanche une
fête de la pleine c'est la deuxième
édition de l'automne c'est sale oui
exactement
on a fait la première édition en
septembre dernier il ya une édition de
printemps en mai et là on remet ça donc
ce week-end 14 et 15 septembre à
crêpière pourquoi organisé justement
cette fête parce que justement nous on
se trouve au coeur de la plaine de
versailles
d'où le nom fait de la plaine et l'idée
c'est de rassembler un maximum de
producteurs locaux
donc on voir des producteurs
alimentaires
donc on va démarrer chez des
confituriers des gens qui font des
boissons voilà plein de plein de bonnes
choses gourmande à venir découvrir et
aussi des artisans
donc ils vont faire des bougies des donc
des choses non alimentaires à des sacs
pleins de plein de belles choses à
découvrir
c'est de montrer finalement toute cette
diversité de le montrer les touts les
richesses donc on est vraiment en lien
avec la paix ppp
là dessus et l'idée c'est de faire re
découvrir tout ce qui se passe
finalement sur sur cette plaine de
versailles qui est très riche où il se
passe plein de choses et donc on arrive
de faire découvrir tout ça à travers un
événement qui sera festif et gourmand
voilà donc sur deux jours avec voir des
animations pour les enfants est ce qu'il
ya un marché de produits du terroir mais
aussi des animations tout at on encore à
peu près 25 exposants alimentaires et
d'autres artisans comme j'ai expliqué il
y aura des concerts tout au long du
week-end le samedi soir il ya un dîner
concert
donc ça va être un moment très festif là
il faut réserver
sur sur notre site
vous retrouvez toutes les informations
sur facebook vous pourrez retrouver
toutes les informations pour l'événement
et le dimanche paraît donc des
animations pour les enfants on a un
atelier du pain jeu donkey organisé le
samedi avec vous et dimanche on a une
personne qui vient à venir faire des
animations pour les enfants autour des
plantes mellifères puisque ça tenait le
thème c'est du miel et des abeilles
d'accord le petit flyer donc y aura
aussi des conférences des tables rondes
autour du miel des abeilles a expliqué
voilà toute la magie de la bei
l'apiculture sur sur ces deux joueurs
clés je rappelle cette fête de la plaine
c'est ce samedi et dimanche rendez vous
à chaque fois de 10h à 19h à crêpière
les aux réactions - 10h 19h plus le
samedi soir avec les social des concerts
qui est de 20 heures à 2 heures du matin
je rappelle toutes les informations à
retrouver sur le site internet des deux
gourmands merci à vous deux merci merci
marie martinez d'être venu parler de ces
événements festifs de l'automne sur la
plaine de versailles est d'ailleurs
n'oubliez pas de faire le plein d'idées
de sorties pour ce week end dans
l'émission le 7-8 loisirs présenté par
wilfrid richy c'est ce soir juste après
ce journal sur tb 78 cet été la commune
de bonnel elle fêté sa réserve en
accueillant habitants et amoureux de la
nature cette journée de rencontres et
découvertes
la commune la mise en place avec le parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse des détails de gwenaëlle
scintillant
et en forêt libellules plantes
aquatiques
ils constituent une partie du patrimoine
de la ville de beaune elle sept communes
de moins de 2000 habitants est située au
coeur du parc de la haute vallée de
chevreuse la réserve naturelle a été
créée en 1990 au départ pour faire face
à la menace d'un projet de golf elle a
été élue capitale française de la
biodiversité en 2018 pour la
préservation de son patrimoine naturel
la ville a donc inauguré ce samedi 6
juillet la fête de la réserve
c'est une reconnaissance c'est pas un
aboutissement donc pour moi c'est
chouette parce que ça veut dire que tout
ce que l'on a fait n'a pas été n'est pas
entièrement idiot et donc on est reconnu
par des gens dont c'est la spécialité
qui est désunie vous avez fait des
choses bien mais après je l'on ne s'en
vantent pas pour autant quoi mais très
sincèrement oui ça fait ça fait ça fait
chaud car oui c'est sûr le parc naturel
de cheuvreux a mis en place une journée
de rencontres et de redécouverte de la
réserve et du parc
cette journée a été organisée dans le
cadre du plan paysager biodiversité des
versions de l'arrivée donc c'est un
secteur sur lequel on est en train de
travailler actuellement pour en fait
créé un outil d'aidé à la décision
notamment pour les élus aujourd'hui
c'était l'idée de faire participer les
habitants à cette démarche là en les
faisant parcourir les paysages et en
leur demandant un peu leur perception
leurs idées sur ce qu'on pourrait faire
justement pour selon eux valoriser ses
paysages des versants de l'arrimage des
conférences et visites guidées de la
réserve était au coeur de l'événement un
moment pour venir contempler
l'exposition de peinture sur des
paysages de la réserve c'est un lieu
reposant apaisant mais c'est vraiment un
lieu où il fait bon peindre une occasion
pour les associations comme l'amicale
des poissons de charte en est bonne elle
bullion nature d'échanger avec les
habitants un moment de convivialité en
famille ou entre amis grâce à une balade
organisée entre deux communes tu qu'on
avait quarante participants qui faisait
aucune randonnée à pied
le maître depuis bonnel jusqu'à forge et
en vélo des forges jusqu'à bonnel pour
revenir jamais entendue par des voisins
en fait c'est un circuit que nous ne
connaissons pas tant les gens de forge
que de bonnes aide puisque c'est un
circuit qui ne peut être que pédestre on
peut pas le faire autrement que à pied
et encore avec autorisation de quelques
propriétaires dont c'est vrai que c'est
du coup circuit très inhabituel duquel
on voit des paysages super sympa quoi et
ça donne envie d'essayer de le rendre
possible par la suite de manière ouverte
pour tout le monde quoi je pense qu au
moins toutes les personnes qui ont
participé à cette à cette balade ont
bien compris qu'il y avait un intérêt
très fort pour tout le monde de
connaître ce paysage pour justement le
respecter
on a des prix ouverte qui sont
extraordinaires des fonds de vallées des
forêts vraiment c'est sympa mais
franchement certaines personnes dix ans
seront en vacances en rando en pleine
campagne à des kilomètres des côtes de
la région parisienne
ça fait plaisir parce que nous sommes
quand même un jeu en équipe de france le
botaniste bernard chevassus-au-louis
président de l'association humanité et
biodiversité a animé un débat suivi par
la projection en plein air du film la
terre vue du coeur une journée de fête
qui se termine tranquillement sur un
transat et puis du sport c'est une
discipline qui mêle golf et foot et
football le foot golf fait de plus en
plus d'adeptes
récemment le golf des yvelines
accueillait la 26e étape de la food gold
cup la foule gold cup on va y arriver
découverte avec maxime abolin et aurélie
rose
fini les clubs et les bals place au
ballon de football sur les parcours de
golf invente rien aux pays-bas en 2009
le foot golf se développe en france on
compte aujourd'hui cinq mille licenciés
et 10000 pratiquants chaque année le fou
de golf en fait c'est comme son nom
l'indiqué du golfe mais avec un ballon
de foot donc globalement la discipline
c'est vraiment un parcours de golf
on a un point et on a
on a un trou dans lequel à mettre le
ballon en moins de coups possible et
donc ça se joue en parcours de 18 trous
au niveau des compétitions et on a
exactement le même vocabulaire que le
golf à savoir là on a des par 3 par
quatre par 5 on va faire des birdy
déboguer départ pas besoin d'être
professionnel pour remplir ses 18 trous
une bonne technique avec le ballon un
oeil aiguisé de golfeurs et le tour est
joué
un mélange qui plaît à ses adhérents
après mois avec les pentes
j'arrive à avoir c'est ce que
recherchent c'est un golfeur mais je
pense que vous fera re des notions golf
de foot et surtout beaucoup de mental je
pense que ça joue beaucoup
c'est un sport on est face à soi même on
peut en vouloir à personne
une dizaine de kilomètres par parcours
le plein air un ballon puisque je suis
un ancien foot est un ancien golfeur
enfin voilà bande de potes un club
extraordinaire donc tous les éléments
sont réunis pour pour cette activité
après l'escale parisienne l'afutt gold
cup continue son tour de la france
trente six étapes sont au programme
avant la grande finale prévue à la fin
de l'année le ballon rond qui sourit est
décidément aux français l'équipe de
france de foot golf est également
championne du monde en titre de sa
discipline
c'est la fin du à 7,8 journal belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]